welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for our presentation titled
simplifying component selection in
lateral
flow assay development it is my pleasure
to introduce you to claus hotchliner
global technology lead in the
diagnostics of sativa
for complete biography of our speaker
please visit the tab at the top
of your screen if you have any questions
that might arise during the presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
a box
our speaker will address your questions
following the end of the presentation
please join me now in welcoming claus
hodgsoner
i will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome sir
wait thank you for the introduction and
welcome to this presentation
on component selection and natural flow
assay development
letter flow essays are rapid tests
that are unrivaled in terms to speed and
ease of use
the point is that their development can
take an awful lot of time so typically
starting
from the test idea over component
sampling and development and design
verification you can easily spend up to
12 months
and including stability tests regulatory
approval
validation scale up it may last a total
of two years
you want to get this step correct and
that means
that you need to select your components
early and in the correct way
in general a lateral flow test consists
of a couple of different materials
that serve different purposes and
the sample flows laterally through these
pads and membranes
and generate your test results
basically we discriminate between two
essay types
one type is called a sandwich test
that's been used if you can bind two
binders to your specific target molecule
blindness can be antibodies can be
antibody fragments can be aphamers or
aptamers
the point is that you can bind two of
them independently to your target
and they do they do not interfere with
each other
the other option is a competitive test
in that case you cannot bind more than
one
binder to your target molecule and that
means you
have a test line that already contains
your target molecule
and in a negative sample your antibody
your detector antibody will bind to that
test line
and if the target is present in the
sample liquid
you will see a decrease the signal at
the test line
while in the sandwich test you see an
increase in the signal the test line
both tests are being used today
and as an example for a sandwich test
that's the well-known
pregnancy test and an example for a
competitive test
would be a drugstore abuse test
typically a later flow manufacturing
process consists of a number of
different steps
so you coat the sample pads and
potentially blood separators and
conjugate pads with appropriate buffers
you apply your detector conjugate to the
conjugate pad and dry
you dispense your chest and control
lines onto the membrane
if necessary you would code even the
wick you will affix
all components to a self-adhesive
backing card
cover this card with a translucent cover
tape if the tests to be sold as a
dipstick
or you will cut the card into strips of
defined width and encapsulate these
strips in a cassette housing it's not to
be sold as a dipstick
so what we have here is a
multi-component system
the advantage of this magic clothing
system is
that this test strip contains all
chemicals and reagents that are required
and it contains them in the drive state
in most cases you need no sample
preparation
at least let's say no external sample
preparation
because you can add a number of buffers
to the sample application pad which is
the first pad in your test
and force your sample to have a specific
iron strength or a specific ph
the enhues adjust adds the sample and
lets the test run
until the results get visible and that
means
it can be handled by lay people
the test result is appearing rapidly
a typical test duration time is
something between 5 and 15 minutes
the obvious disadvantage is it's a
multi-component system
and it's very challenging in development
and manufacturing
when you develop an lfa labeled
antibodies
or aphemers optomers other binders like
scrap evidence or neutral vitamin
capture binders and the test membrane
are all integral to the success of a
lateral flow essay
and that means you have to have a
thorough selection process
and you must ensure that these
components work together
and you have to have an eye on the
properties of your sample liquid
and the specific of the target molecule
that you want to detect
selection optimization of binders is
important step
but these binders communicate with the
membrane if you want to say so
and that's sometimes not being addressed
correctly during lfa development
let's talk about that reaction memory
so the key considerations is on a couple
of parameters which we'll discuss
as far as they are important for your
chest development and we will talk about
kepler rise time about membrane backing
about blocking the membrane and about
membrane surfactants
and we will come back to that specific
point later
very often the correct choice of the
membrane
uh will come down to the nature of the
nature of the test being designed
and it may be reasonable to test many
product
variants so capillary rise time
what is that that's the time that a
liquid and typically this is water
needs to flow a defined distance on the
membrane and typically this is 40
millimeters and that's being used
as in process controls and memory
manufacturing
and it's what we call a specification
parameter
and at the lower left of that slide you
see
what determination of capillary flow
time or capillary rise time
looks like typically membranes are
characterized
by a specification that has a
specification
mean for example 80 to 100 seconds for
a very fast membrane and
um it has specification limits which we
will discuss
in a minute very uh fast membranes are
being used
for things like saliva receptor will
like solids
medium fast membranes which typically
have a flow time
of approximately 120 to 135
seconds as specification means will be
used for
things like blood serum and plasma or
for urine
and very slow membranes which have a
flow time
of roughly 180 seconds will be used for
things like water
all suppliers manufactures the membrane
to a defined capillary rise time
and that's our the main specification
parameter when we manufacture membranes
while this capillary rise time
specification has an
upper and a lower limit
and that means you have to take care
that your reagents or your test results
are working the same way on both ends
of the specification limit
if you have an issue with membrane
specification parts
at the fast end you can easily see false
negative results the sample runs too
quickly
across the membrane and you do not see
the result on the test line that you
would like to see at
the detection limit if you have an issue
with the slow part of a membrane
specification
you may get false positive signals or
you will have an issue with membrane
clearance that means the membrane
is not white again when
the test duration time is over
in rare cases we see issues at both
edges of the specification and then it's
getting really difficult
um what you should do is you should test
membrane samples from both edges of the
specifications
something that we call limiting samples
and look for the performance of your
test
it might be that you have to select a
different membrane rate
if you run into trouble or it might be
that you will have to ask for
a customized membrane a membrane that
works
with your tests and has its own
capillary rise time specifications
an important point here is that binders
are although they have the same affinity
constant
may be different in terms of the on and
off rate
of are the binding reaction
for lateral flow tests you would be
interested in very fast on rates because
the interaction times that you have
available
at the test line but also for the
conjugate are
very very short antibodies that have the
same affinity but have
slow on rates and slow off rates are
typically eliza antibodies
they will not work perfectly well in
lateral flow sa test
so if you have a bunch of antibodies
available
you should try to get surface plus one
resonance data
that describes the only afraid of the
binders
if you have just one pair available and
no choice uh for selecting
another reagent you will have to play
with the speed of the membrane
so if you have to use binders that have
relatively slow on rate you will have to
use a slow membrane
if you want to have a chance to reach
your detection limit
membrane backing well what is that um
when you manufacture
nitrocellulose membranes uh what is
being done
is the nitrocellulose raw materials are
dissolved in organic solvents with
boiling points lower than that of water
uh these casting mixes are poured onto a
solid sulfur
surface typically a steel belt if you
want to have an
unpacked membrane or a plastic belt if
you want to have a back membrane
the membrane is formed on that support
and in case of the back membrane
it's not lift lifted off the support
so it stays there um the advantage is
as mechanical stability you will not be
able to tear that apart
the disadvantage is you have to live
with the upper side of the membrane
and what that means you see on the right
part of that slide
uh what you see here is two electron
micrographs
of an unbacked membrane that's called
a100
that's a fast uh electroflow membrane
and what you see that the upper side
which we call the air side
has a relatively coarse structure um
obviously a random structure which is
typical for nitrocellulose membranes
ah but the right side which is the bell
side the part of the membrane that was
forming directly on top of this support
steel belt
um has a denser structure which means a
higher protein binding capacity
and it looks more regular so it's not as
variable as the air side
if you want to use an unbacked membrane
use both sides
and it could be very advantageous to use
than the bell site
the downside is the mechanical stability
of an unbacked membrane
and especially for beginners in the
field our recommendation is
use the back memory
the nitrous cellulose matrix of the
membrane binds proteins
and you like that you want this membrane
to bind proteins
as long as you dispense your chest and
control lines
as soon as these binders have been bound
by the membrane you are left
with an awful lot of membrane area
that's still
open has not bind anything yet this
membrane
would bind anything it would find in
your sample liquid
your target your detector reagent
whatever
you offer and that means
you will have to block these three
areas in order to prevent them from
interact
with your target or your detector and
there's two options
at first you can do something
um that's called block on the fly in
that case blocking reagents
are part of the pre-treatment buffers of
your sample pad or your conjugate pad
these reagents are dissolved by the
sample liquid
they migrate with the sample
and block the membrane while the sample
liquid is moving across the membrane
and that's the reason why it's called
block on the fly
the advantage of this process is
a cost reduction because the alternative
is blocking in a separate manufacturing
step
in that case um the membrane
is treated with the tests and
controlling reagents the reagents
are dried and then the membrane is
soaked
in a buffer or you spray a buffer onto
the membrane
that contains the blocking reagents
a separate manufacturing step means
another step that needs to be tested
developed validated
and of course it's the cost factor in
manufacturing
the advantage is you have full control
over the amount of blocking regions that
you apply
to the membrane if you do block on the
fly
you have to live with the thickness
variability of the pads that are in
front of the membrane
and that means you will have different
concentrations of blocking reagents in
your migrating liquid
since you will have variable thickness
and it means
variable pen volume but you will always
apply the same
volume to your cassette housing or your
to your dipstick
and that means your sample liquid is
always the same
it's always the same volume but the
amount of
molecules dissolved in it when it runs
through the pads
will differ that's especially difficult
when you want to develop
a quantitative test system and for
quantitative tests
a separate blocking step of the membrane
is more or less unavoidable
many people are not aware of the fact
that the reaction membrane
contains a surfactant
all nitrocellulose membranes contain
surfactants
and the surfactants are needed because
the nitrocellulose membranes are quite
hydrophobic matrices they only disaffect
and
make them really hydrophilic so
surfactants have been a part in
nitrocellulose membranes since they're
very infancy
and the oldest pattern that i could find
was from 1917 so it's more than 100
years old
and even that membrane already contained
as the fact
in protein applications
not only letter flow but also flow
through tests or
western blots these surfactants help to
mobilize your binding proteins
to the membrane matrix different
suppliers use
different surfactants and apply them at
different stations of the manufacturing
process
so it makes sense to test membranes from
different suppliers
for your specific application
this denaturation process
binds proteins to membranes and you need
that
the problem is this process denatures
proteins
it can easily be that in the monoclonal
antibody or the
female or the aptamer that you are using
the surfactant
destroys the binding site
or at least reduces its activity
in that case you may have to switch to
another membrane that contains
a different surfactant or worst case
you may have to look for
different binders i have worked with
more than thousand different monoclonal
antibodies and all kinds of other
binders
um during my work in leftover flow
diagnostics
and from what i've seen is two to three
percent of all monoclonal antibodies
that means two to three percent of the
clones do
not work on membranes because the
antigen binding sites
are destroyed by anionic surfactants
and in that case although it's a rare
case
there is no way out you can't make that
run on a nitrocellulose membrane
and you have to look for a different
binder
but even if you can immobilize your
antibodies successfully
um you should keep in mind that
um that this immobilization is a random
one
that means the antibody is not bound
with its fc
part to the membrane and the antigen
binding sites are protruding
into the free migrating liquid
any orientation of the antibody is
possible
and there's two things that you have to
look for one is
is that a preferential orientation that
blocks the binding sites because the
binding sites binding to the membrane
in that case you have a problem was the
antibody antigen interaction
and the second question is
how close are the two binders
to each other once they bind to your
target
if they are too close you will run into
trouble with
steric hindrance especially in membranes
that
can easily happen and our recommendation
is
you should do epitope mapping using
surface plasmon resonance to make sure
that your antibodies are doing what they
want them to do
without interfering with each other
it can also gives you reliable data
about on and off rates
and you could also test for
inconsistencies
from batch to batch and you can test
for lack of compatibility with the use
of specific reagents
what you also have is pads on the left
and the right side
of the membrane so you have a sample pad
that you can coat with buffers
that may contain reagents that block the
membrane
but typically and much more importantly
they contain reagents that take care
that at least some key parameters of
your sample will always look the same
after the sample has dissolved this
buffer that you have coated into the
sample pack
an example is urine urine is coming
with a quite acidic ph in the morning
and it's get
gets alkaline in the same patient
towards the evening so a typical range
in ph is something between 6.5 and eight
what you can easily see that especially
specific binders like monoclonal
antibodies
change their binding characteristic when
you change the ph
um it makes an awful lot of sense to
take care that every urine
regardless when it was collected has the
same ph when it runs across the test
and this is what you achieve in the
sample pattern your sample pad may also
be a blood separator
as the name says it's being used when
you use whole blood as a sample
and its task is to remove the blood
cells especially the red blood cells
um still the main detector particle
electro flow rapid test
is gold gold nanoparticles and that's
red
and if your red blood cells leak onto
your membrane you try to look for a red
signal on a red background
and it's not very likely to give you
very good signal to noise ratios and
that
is what you why you need a blood
separator
and then you have your conjugate pad um
that's the most tricky part of the test
to be honest
um because what you expected to do as
you expected to absorb the conjugate
path that you'll
dispense on it um and the liquid form
and you definitely should dispense and
she should not soak the pad with
the detector then you dry the conjugate
in the pad
and you would like this conjugate to
remain stable and not be destroyed
during the drying process
and then you expect after a year of
storage
in a drugstore a household
a doctor's office under more or less do
these environmental conditions
uh you in earnest expect the conjugate
pad
when the sample enters the conjugate pad
to release this dry conjugate into the
sample and make it run across the test
and the detector reagent on the
conjugate
uh is supposed to find structure to bind
it
as it would do it um before
you have applied it to the pad and
that's a very
uh interesting expectation and
mistakes are during preparation of
conjugate spirits
are are the most likely root cause if
you run into trouble with your epic
chest
and finally you'll have an absorption
pad
often referred to as a wick the task of
this pad
is to capture a sample liquid and to
retain it
what you should take care of is that the
absorption capacity of this wick
is much larger than the volume of the
sample liquid that you apply
because what you have here is a
matrix that generates your results
that's the membrane
which is very thin compared to all other
pads
it will dry first and then you create a
concentration gradient
um and what you can see then
as a backflow from the wake onto the
membrane
which will give you all kinds of
unspecific
uh weird phenomena on the membrane and
you do not want that to happen you would
like to
have the membrane wide as long as
possible
um some faqs and some common issues
um very often i'm asked what is the pore
size of your nitrocellulose membrane
in plastic membrane back membranes the
pore size cannot determine directly
that's due to the plastic backing and
that's the reason why all membrane
manufacturers refer to capillary
rise time or capillary flow time uh as a
specification parameter
as a rule of thumb a very fast membrane
has a very large pore size
um and a given sample liquid
will run faster through a very fast
membrane
uh than it does through a slow membrane
the point is
depending on the properties of your
reagents
especially if the capture reagent on the
test line
a fast membrane is likely to give you a
lower sensitivity as compared to a slow
membrane
um as said it depends also on the
properties of your capturing agents
a capture reagent with an extremely high
on rate
gives you a very good sensitivity
even on a very fast membrane a capture
reagent
that has a disaster of an on rate might
not even work on the slowest memory that
you can buy in the marketplace
another question is what adhesive is
used
in your back membranes
no membrane manufacturer is using an
adhesive to create
a plastic bag membrane
these back membranes are 100 micrometer
thick polyester supports onto which the
casting mix
is poured and the membrane is for on
this polyester support and it stays this
by simple adhesion um
adhesives come into play once you
laminate
these membranes onto the backing onto
which you also have to fix
all the pads that you need to create
your wrapping test
a number of couple a couple of issues as
listed on the right of the slides um
including possible solution so what is
frequently seen uneven lines or dots
during the dispensing process
um you may use different membranes with
different capillary flow times
um you may use the dispensing rate of
the reagent
perhaps including reducing the
dispensing volume
if you do that you may have to increase
the protein concentration of the reagent
you will take care
of the buffer composition and you will
check your dispensing process
and although many people don't like to
hear that
um in a sizable number of cases
the reason for uneven lines and dots
is lack of maintenance of the dispensers
so it makes sense to clean them properly
and to take care of their function
false positive signals um
in terms of of membrane issues
can be modified uh by changing the
buffer in the conjugates
are you make peak uh tweak the ph to
salt concentration you may play around
with surfactants
and worst case if that you have to
change a conjugated protein
for false negative results um a
typical solution would be to
reduce the capillary rise time that
means to use a slower membrane
this very often leads to a better
sensitivity of
a test increasing the sample volume
is also an option but there are limits
to that in the lateral flow test
so the typical sample volume is 100
microliters
you can use something like two perhaps
300 microliters the idea to run one
milliliter
across a lateral flow test is simply not
feasible so there is an upper limit to
that
uh what is also sometimes seen as uneven
liquid fronts of migrating samples
it might be that you have stored your
membrane too long
but in most cases it's a problem with
either that you're using a relatively
hydrophobic membrane that means a
membrane that has
a very low surfactant content and the
other option is that you have a problem
with the relative humidity
in the room and if this is too low uh
then you will see
flow issues another question worth
the hydrophobicity of membranes is a
very interesting one
um hydrophobic membranes or let's say
membranes that have a low surfactant
content they're not really hydrophobic
can easily give you better better
sensitivities because
they have a less negative impact on your
binders
especially on the test line um you can
modify the uh hydrophilicity of the
membrane then
by playing around with the blocking
muscle
so a membrane that is relatively
hydrophobic and you like that because it
gives you a better sensitivity
should be blocked in a separate
manufacturing step because
then you can deal with uh any
uneven liquid fronds or migration issues
that you see
and still have a better sensitivity
than you would have with a high
surfactant memory
so to summarize that uh the
nitrocellulose membrane
is the core of your electro flow essay
because this is
where the end user sees the test result
getting the right membrane first time or
at least
as soon as possible is key in
keeping your letter flow test
development and on track within
specification and on budget
um choosing a membrane is not just
simply using
a paper it needs to be considered
alongside a lot of other key decisions
and it has to be done in our conjunction
with
reagent selection the membrane needs to
be able to immobilize antibodies it
should not affect their binding
capabilities
and it must enable sample to flow at the
optimal speed and
it makes a lot of sense to work closely
with your membrane manufacturer
to discuss our common pitfalls or to
discuss
uh what can be done and what cannot be
done with a given set of reagents
uh and perhaps to design in a membrane
that's
manufactured according to your needs
and if you have questions please feel
free to talk to us
thank you
thank you claus for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation
claus will unfortunately not be able to
join us for this portion
but we do have lee jenkins joining us
senior
product leader for sativa welcome lee
and i just want to remind our audience
members to please submit their questions
via the q a box looks like we already
have some great questions coming in lee
so let's get started
our first question is what are the
common
reasons why people fail to develop a
viable
test okay
yes thank you and yeah distribute
apologies to everybody that close can't
be here
for the q a session but um hopefully i
can help answer these questions and
anything you wish to discuss with
us we can take offline so with regards
to the common reasons why people fail
close they did a excellent job
in the video i'm talking about different
reasons but essentially
you know i think to summarize what he
presented there are many different
factors involved
in developing the test so it could be
anything from
the detection here um your detection
reagents
reagent use which pads membranes you
select
the backing card selections or even the
working environment
and equipment set up so every single
factor involved
will affect the overall performance and
test so in terms of
test development failure it really does
depend case by case
and you know we can help you with your
troubleshooting if you need this support
but um we support that we suggest that
look at maybe the capture region
selection or
the texture selection and regions of the
tests
are probably a key place to start but
unfortunately you'd have to test all of
those items
thank you so much lee our next question
why does the test
take so long to develop for example the
covid19 test
golden question so everybody wants
of the quicker development and
[Music]
to develop a normal lasso flow test can
take
two to three years to keep a customer
get from development
get through clinical trials and get onto
the market
and two probably a good robust test
you know normally you take an absolute
minimum of one year at the r d
phase so let's go through the whole tech
transfer and scale up after that
the stability trials obviously requires
time as well
so everyone's working with absolute
urgency
um doing the kind of pandemic get test
as quick as possible
but you know we need to allow type
development for the optimization
in order to fulfill all the needs um
understanding cod is a special situation
and we do have some emergency use
authorization to bypass some of the
timelines
but you know it still takes time to go
for such a complex
development and hopefully klaus is 30
minutes this
presentation you know touched on some of
the elements of why they take quite so
long to
complete the process
thank you so much lee can you talk to
the audience a little bit about the
development
of challenges of multiplexing
okay yeah that's another good question
so
i guess first of all there's several
different types of multiplexing assays
so you could have a array of strips
you could have spatial separation or
detection sites
you could have a broad selective
recognition element
or you could have a variable signal
reporter
and the primary consideration when
contemplating
multiplexing in a later flow essay would
be about the cross reactivity
and interference between the assays
because this might impact your signal
the sample treatment method
compatibility
the sensitivity and dynamic range
of each part of the test um each of the
targets that we try to detect
the stability and you know the assay
format
you know it is a mix of sandwich i see
it's involved then
this has a whole extra level of
complexity
when talking about a multiplex i see
you know a membrane which never shallows
you select is a
key element so we suggest that when
developing mother effects that flow i
see
they need to consider upfront the number
of test legs they require
the viscosity of the sample the desired
or
at the very least the acceptable test
runtime
the kinetic properties of the cutting
regions
and then as close touched on the list
the memory inspectors must be very
important
and that would need tested and something
a different membrane what works well
with your rsa
thank you so much i want to thank our
audience members for these great
questions coming in
lee what blocking agents are typically
used and how does the
impact um how does this impact flow rate
for example okay so
normally we block our conjugate parts
and let's
tell those membranes for the conjugate
parts the
purpose of the blocking is to make the
conjugate stable during the whole shelf
life of the test
so make your conjugate release
efficiency
and you know repeat the both from the
conjugate part
you can start to block your conjugate
parts by
you know developing several different um
formations so
we have a standard process of a
boring a psa buffer that we use but
i'd suggest that if you're in contact
with our
teams after the meeting we can help
share some details of what we've used
previously
but people need to keep in mind that
different part materials
and different tests will require
different buffers so there's not one
bespoke solution which is why i'm a
little bit hesitant
to share too much on this question
with regards to the nightmare cellulose
the purpose of blocking the membrane
is to reduce the unspecific binding of
protein
so different concentrations of bsa can
be tested as a blocking buffer here to
see
how the impact is on your protest
thank you so much and how do you start
to evaluate membranes
based on what surfactant can
they use okay so
yeah i think clouds did again a session
on this but the surfactant
is a very important factor of night
cellulose
you know he mentioned that all labor
cellulose is on the market
hundreds of atoms present generally
different types so you need to
understand that not all
monoclonal antibodies will work well in
a presence of a given surfactant
that's plant body testing in the
presence of various surfactants
and it's critical to optimize the
performance
so we've got you know a feeling i would
say that about
three percent of my problems bodies will
not work in the presence of
any surfactant so others may only work
at low surface
uh low surfactant concentrations so it's
getting very much around that testing
evaluating you know trying to test and
broaden the range as possible during
your
early development stages um different
surfactants
in the membranes may lead to different
test results so
you may get changes in sensitivity you
know
positive or negative um influences on
your test or
you may get false positives if you are
not compatible so
that's really key to the testing
elements and then
also the way this factors introduce the
membrane can have a big influence on the
results
so we have different product families at
city
of neptulos where the majority of our
grades such as the
ffhp grades we add surfactants the cast
in mix
and we do this because we believe that
it gives a more
consistent mix of distractions to the
membrane
some other product families that we
release or that
our competitors have available they post
treat
the product after manufacturers the fact
that
again it can have a different impact on
your performance positive or negative so
we encourage you to test
both to see what works well for yourself
but
you know it may lead to more variability
or less
consistency of surfactant you use a
post-treated
membrane the type of surfactants
concentration of the spectrums
they're all proprietary to each membrane
supplier so they're not going to
necessarily tell you what's the fact
that's included but
you know we suggest if you talk to our
application specialists they can give
you more information on
you know what they regard regarding our
memory interactions and what could work
for your test
wonderful thank you so much emily what
are the scale-up
factors that one needs to consider
during the test development
so before i answer this i guess the the
best answer for today is there's a
session
later in the summit about scaling up
your development
so we've got arvind health talking about
the importance of
a contract manufacturing organization
and talking to them early in your
development so join
john's session today to understand
exactly what's involved there
we also have five dots coming on at the
end of the event to talk about
how they can bring scale of the test but
from our side as a component supplier
well we suggest that you
choose materials from high quality
suppliers with
you know appropriate levels of technical
support ensure the
membranes you are putting available at a
large scale and that there's no capacity
concerns
that's especially critical at the moment
because around copper 19 we see in
you know some suppliers are having a run
on memory of
the normal level of availability that
they would have had previously
consider dispensing remembering reaches
to non-contact methods
so this can just help your automation
and the volume
possible immersion processes if possible
use conveyance conjugates which are
appropriately optimized and stabilized
uh whatever suggestions i got um use
inline processing
and automated process controls
use a controlled manufacturing
environment and then
in your development concentrate on
appropriate device design
and assembly method so that you've got a
test which can go
from a lab-based test into a full
automation skill test
again if anyone needs any support over
these skill
conversations you know please speak to
our teams they can help pay you on
suggestions of what we can provide you
thank you so much lee and thank you
again to our audience
this next audience member
poses a question from their own lab and
hopefully
can get some assistance from you
he writes besides we consider the
capillary flow of the membrane
is there any other factor which could
help to control the capillary
speed for example they have a problem
with their capillary flow right now
and that their assay is too fast and
they've tried to add
surf surfactants or even blockers for
the membrane
but it wasn't significant can you help
them with this problem
i can but also i'd suggest that you know
if they want to
reach out to any of our contacts or any
other field application support teams
they can
discuss stay specifically but at a high
level
the advice i can give is that the
surfactant generally will not help slow
down
the reflow type this is not something
that the
spark that brings to the membrane
lock-in can help
a little bit but again not
a huge um contribution the most
significant way of affecting the flow
rate
would be looking at the membrane
and the pods that you use the assay
so the wick and the sample conjugate
parts and what is the
working rate of those but also what's
the photon of the megacellos
the tri pads and membranes which have a
slower rating for the working and
complete flow times so all
membranes and parts are released with
membrane speeds
so talk to your supplier understand what
they have
um what memories you have now where that
is in the
the range and try to select something
with a higher reading it's a higher
measurement which gives you a slower
lower membrane you can even talk to your
map your supplier and see if you know
if you seem to fit in between two parts
you're not getting a
correct level of sensitivity let's see
if they give you a custom flow membrane
which is the higher end of a
specification due to the test
now outside of that it's probably
looking at the affinity binding rate of
your detection pay
you know you need to go back to do
something like spr analysis to
understand your own operates
using vehicle or something similar but
you know this can
often mean we started the whole
development process and
you know we were just looking at the
parts and remembering your first
simple step wonderful thank you so much
i hope that helps her
our next question can the choice of
antibody
type for example antibodies optomers
affirmers affect the flexibility of
choice
of nc membranes and ultimately the speed
of the assay
yeah um another one where it
really depends so typically
the capture reagents will work
differently
with different pollutants and sparkling
types
i wouldn't say that there is any
restriction or flexibility around choice
but it goes back to you know demand for
doing development
test as many different varieties as
possible
when you're selecting your membrane to
departs you know
test different families different speeds
to understand what performance you're
getting
if you're able to take to test your
affinity binding of the pair
you know via the spl analysis which you
know i just mentioned vehicles a way of
doing that
then again it can help you understand
what capability you have in your chest
but unfortunately it's going to be a
trial and error activity for the
customer
thank you so much we have time for a few
more questions is it possible to obtain
a highly sensitive and quick reaction by
changing the antibody type
rather than the membrane test itself
membrane itself yeah okay
so if you have a test which is running a
present with
a antibody and you're looking just to
switch that over to the activator
that's highly unlikely because it's you
know very rare
in natural flow and the test that you
are able to make a
simple swap out of one component to
another especially something as critical
as the
detection regions um
you probably would have to go back
through the whole redevelopment and
essentially
it becomes developing a new test looking
at different protection types
you could get faster speeds and you
might need
um you know a more sense you might get
a more sensitive assay but it all really
depends on
your thinking binding rate and how it's
compatible from
your all components in your test so
again
not the direct answer but it's very
specific if you have a test that you
want to help you talk to
again i encourage you to contact one of
our team offline we can have discussions
with you
but um it's not a one-size-fits-all
solution to this answer
thank you so much lee now if we inject
for example
two proteins into a membrane but when
checked
only one protein appears
what does one do and whether do they
replace the membrane or the process for
the protein
that must be correct
yeah and it's all good to discuss very
specific
cases such as this in a general format
but know in more detail
i don't want to keep referring to the
same response but you know if
the customer process we can separate
and talk a lot more detail about their
tests and understand
exactly what they're doing to you know
consider all aspects um
from a high level it's quite all
you know but it's good to see what could
be
thank you so much yeah of course yes
when you're after the 321
no problem how do you minimize serum
interference in the serology lfa okay so
the simplest way of
minimizing interference is by having a
good blood separator
um clouds touched on in a presentation
very briefly
that separate is available but you
should essentially
try different um sample volumes and
different
separators to understand what would be
your test
there is a lot of information out there
and different suppliers do have
different
separators if you need more advice and i
advise person to look through to the
saikiva website where we do have some
content around
what different separators and how this
can work within their tests so
encourage you to get in contact if you
need samples from us to
see what works well and we can happily
supply these to you
thank you so much nelly our next
audience member has a question about
validity and reliability
if things like humidity and the shelf
life of the membrane
can impact the test and assuming
packaging
can mitigate this to an extent but not
completely
would the typical validation line at the
end of the test
be the only method to determine a faulty
test
and if so how reliable will it be
very interesting so the
validation line i assume you mean the
control line
uh so yes this would be you know
obviously
your north star as we say so this would
be your
ultimate way of understanding once the
test is developed now if it's failed
but i would go back to that this is all
about development
this question so ensuring that you have
a rigorous development that you are
fully testing the stability during your
early processes that you are
understanding the capability of your
assay
you don't want to do this once you've
got through development and you've got a
product on the market
if you're relying on a control line tell
your
the test is faulty or not you know
you're in serious trouble
you want to understand all of this very
early in the process understand the
shuffling for your conjugates
how stable they are when suspended
someone's stride understands
the stability of your whole test and the
only way to do this is by stability
trials and
a rigorous development process
thank you so much and again what a great
lively conversation from our audience
today
what are the reasons for getting those
ghost bands
with capture antibody on the top test
line and how do i get rid of it
again it's one that sounds very specific
to this customer's essay so
hard to give a an answer which is going
to be definitive
you so
again feel free to contact our team's
offline where we can help discuss
this but um clouds outlined in the
presentation some
ways where we have you know faint lines
or these post
it's all generally about looking at your
not specific finding or having a look at
your
dispensing rates around the test it's
something which
you know we could have talked more
details offline but
very difficult to get exploring kind of
give you a definitive answer on what
would work first
unfortunately wonderful thank you and
the same audience member wants to know
what is the optimum capture antibody
concentration
for the test line yeah
again it's going to be very specific to
your test uh what on the bodies you're
using what you're trying to detect
not able to give you a definitive answer
on that in this forum
um if we want to talk about we can give
you some examples
of you know what concentrations we use
for different targets
and we can say from our experience what
works well
but such a broad um
statement across that whole muscle flow
very difficult
we have time for one more question we i
have a problem this is coming from an
audience member
i have a problem with assay sensitivity
and suggested to add
stacking pads on it could you recommend
some suitable properties for the
stacking pad
and should we treat the stacking pad
with a buffer
for example
yeah um so if you've got sensitivity
issues in your test then this could help
but no by no means it's gonna be the
only solution for you
um difficult again to understand without
knowing what your test is um
important considerations when you look
at your part would be
what working rates you want or what
absorbency you want from your pad
um no you might want a buffer whether
the chase buffer or whether you want the
blocking solution
they could help but again we really
would need to understand your specific
essay you know let's comment in more
detail over
what would be appropriate for this test
unfortunately
thank you so much lee jenkins we are out
of time i want to thank you would you
like to provide any closing remarks to
our audience before we close today
yes just uh thank you for being joined
in um
you know i've mentioned quite a few
times that
there's not a one-size-fits-all answer
for everything and
it is very case-specific so you know
please
i encourage all our customers if they
are interested we are more than happy to
continue this conversation offline
get in contact with your local account
managers or your local
field application support and we can
help um
talk more specific to you
thank you thank you thank you again sir
and i want to thank claus for his time
as well and i want to thank our audience
for their outstanding questions and
their participation
just as a reminder any questions that
were submitted
but not answered today by our speaker
will be addressed via email
and this presentation will be available
for on-demand viewing
for 12 months please remember to share
it with your colleagues
who may have been interested in this
topic but missed today
and don't miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda visit the
agenda tab
in the auditorium for a full listing
take care and thank you again for your
participation until next time
stay safe and stay healthy bye